the Queen traversed the mall admits the
sights and sounds that have accompanied
her every move during the Jubilee
celebrations
the staying power of the British public
is nothing to a monarch of 86 who kept
on smiling for days into a grueling
schedule and without her biggest
cheerleader at her side in Prince
Philip's place a lady-in-waiting company
yes but on such a day the monarch would
surely have liked the man she calls her
constant strength beside her
fanfare greeted the defender of the
faith that some Paul's Cathedral
chance of god saved the Queen could be
heard as she emerged to join a vast
congregation which reflected her family
life and her very public
responsibilities
this was to be a service of thanksgiving
for six decades on the throne a more
formal affair than the event so far but
still one which pointed to the
personality of the monarch and the
personal sacrifices she has made what we
remember is the simple statement of
commitment made by a very young woman
away from home suddenly and
devastatingly bereaved a statement that
she would be there for those she
governed that she was dedicating herself
to them in all her public engagements
our queen has shown a quality of joy in
the happiness of others she has
responded with just the generosity st.
Paul speaks of in showing honor to [ __ ]
clis local communities and individuals
of every background and class and race
she has made her public happy and all
the signs are that she is herself happy
fulfilled and at home in these
encounters the same of course can
manifestly be said of Prince Phillip and
our prayers and thoughts are very much
with him
the prince was said to be very
disappointed to miss the final day of
his wife celebrations but with her
children and grandchildren at her side
the Queen looked genuinely contented
touched by the effort so many had gone
to and would continue to go to
the members of London's livery
representing trades from grocers to gun
makers fishmongers to fruiterers threw a
lavish lunch for the Windsor plan at
Westminster Hall when you came to the
throne there was talk of a new
Elizabethan age much has changed in the
last six decades but it has been the age
of Elizabeth a sentiment which echoed
across the capital as the crowds
gathered again in their thousands for
what promise to be the highlight of an
already impressive day
if the Brits do one thing well its
pageantry and the afternoon's events
didn't disappoint
the Queen headed a procession guaranteed
to WoW the public
the breastplates of the household
cavalry glittering the sound of horses
hooves echoing right along the mouth
the Duke and Duchess of Cambridge
stirring memories of their wedding last
year appearing again in an open-top
carriage along the same loop they travel
that day
thousand servicemen and women lined the
streets
tens of thousands of royal enthusiasts
followed filling the Mau pushing their
way forward planning out to fill the
space in front of Buckingham Palace
where a royal balcony appearance was
promised and then in an all-too British
moment it happened the heavens opened
the umbrellas came out and soon beneath
teeming skies so did three generations
of the Windsor fire
a mighty roar went up Her Majesty
delighted
despite the rain a much-anticipated fly
past went ahead first aircraft from the
RAF Battle of Britain Memorial Flight
roared their salute
but it was the aerial skills of the red
arrows that really got everyone going
the end of the day the end of the
celebrations built to a crescendo with a
fusillade of shots the belting out for
the umpteenth time in recent days of the
national anthem
and finally three cheers for the Queen
delivered with even greater Guster than
usual
you got the sense people meant it that
the Queen loved it and that those who
pulled off this mammoth celebration will
go away with the sense of a job very
well done Michele Clifford Sky News